welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is nate and so far on this podcast
i believe you guys have made ninety four
thousand three hundred forty six dollars
and ninety eight cents yeah that's
pretty good that's exactly wow i'm not
gonna remembering these numbers what a
good intro that was great the best one
yet hey i think we should address the
elephant in the room here there's
already an elephant uh yeah uh you have
a tall mic stand and we both have small
ones
i don't know what to say guys i mean uh
yeah i wasn't the one who set up the the
room this was not so we wanted to order
three of them from amazon and you could
get two of them delivered the next day
just fine but you throw in a third one
and then all of a sudden it was
delivered on monday
so no actually okay now the actual
behind me okay we should talk about the
actual elephants in the room it's this
uh the studio we got a new studio check
out the behind the scenes on the clips
channel but uh yeah thanks for coming
nate this is huge we've been trying to
do this for a very very long time yeah i
feel like i'm in vegas for some reason
like every couple of months for one
reason or another so the last couple
times it didn't work out because we just
had different schedules but this time it
worked out so it's exciting yeah it's
exciting to have you on because you're
the millionaire who sold everything and
now lives in a lives in a van i don't
yeah i guess so yeah it's a truck but
yeah it's uh that's a dream it's a dream
yeah so many people i think just
uh have that fantasy of just like you
know i'm just gonna sell everything and
just be on the road
yeah it's like a short like probably a
short-term thing like i need to get it
out of my system and just do it in my
life now because i'm 23. and i feel like
it's gonna be a lot tougher to do that
if i have a bunch of kids and i'm 35 and
it's like you know i got to take them to
school and stuff can't move into a van
then right so uh it just felt like the
right time to do it for me so how long
are you thinking about doing that though
i started it in may um
i i really don't know probably for like
a year and then after that i'm just
gonna keep it and then use it like for
random vacations you know like when i
want to go somewhere just get in the
truck and just drive and and go camping
in it but you're planning on stopping
like stopping the full time living in it
yes in one calendar year uh yeah
probably like in the next 12 to 18
months because like you couldn't do it
forever you know like living in a in a
tight space like that like it is nice
having a kitchen and you know like all
those other amenities so um but it's
definitely a fun life experience
but this isn't something that you just
decide you woke up one morning you're
like i'm gonna do this how long was the
planning process like what was involved
when did you first start to get this
idea that you wanted to just get rid of
your apartment you know okay okay it was
uh maybe sixth grade seventh grade had a
really good friend and we would just
talk about yeah i'm gonna go live in a
van one day and then he did that like
two years ago and so i watched him
convert his van he did like a full
conversion he's living out in in
colorado uh now he's in utah right now
um he's been doing it for a couple years
and i was like hell he did it i should
do it too um there wasn't a lot holding
me back on it so it was just like
it's just you know good time to do it
how did you find the van uh it's it's
actually a truck so it's it's a it's a
ford f-250 i mean all right yeah it's i
don't know i'll stop calling
i mean like the truck
it's like van life but it's it's a it's
a ford f250s okay um yeah i bought it
for like 19 grand
right before i think this was right
before like the used car market really
came to like gorilla so it was actually
a decent deal i think on it um and then
i just put like a truck cap on it pretty
tight space i should have driven it over
here so you guys can yeah i would have
loved to have seen that seriously yeah
graham stefan reacts to my truck
it's it's a pretty tight quarter it's
not gonna lie i don't think you could
fit you know uh much in there it's uh i
have to be very selective about what i
bring into this yeah i'm like all right
i can't buy this item because it's just
there's no room like i need to
count every square inch did you have to
get rid of all of your possessions or
did you get like a temporary storage
locker or something no so um my brother
just bought a house so i kind of you
know i was like hey mike you know like
there's there's obvious things that
you're not gonna get rid of um you know
like certain sentimental things um
and i kind of gave him my furniture
because when i broke my lease from my
apartment it was the perfect timing
where he just moved into his house i was
like hey you want my couch do you want
my like other like carpets and
everything so it worked out perfectly um
so that's kind of where i put some of my
stuff yeah what do you take with you
uh on the road yeah
uh just the basics i mean you know i
have my laptop i was gonna bring my imac
and i was gonna put that in the truck
and it's like a huge imac um but two
problems with that i didn't want to get
stolen but also it was it just didn't
fit like it did not fit in the back of
the truck because i can sit back and i
can like edit videos yeah um on top of
that you know just some some clothes uh
you know have to do laundry like once a
week cause i don't have a ton of clothes
um
i have a cooler i didn't put a fridge in
there yet i want to build a fridge and
like a whole version two of the the
truck maybe in like a few more months um
yeah now why why a truck why not just go
like kind of glamping get like an rv get
one of these like professional the big
things where you look at that you're
like wow
like the the they do all the vacation
movies and the big you know the camper
i mean okay first of all like i feel
like i don't really need that it's more
fun to be more stealth when you're doing
it so um i can just pull up and park
anywhere and just sleep in it because
nobody expects somebody to be sleeping
in the back of a truck like it looks
very normal um
and also i want to be able to use the
truck you know after i'm done with this
whole
time in my life i'll probably just take
the cap off the truck use it as a
regular truck for work and for hauling
stuff around so uh that was kind of the
reasoning behind that do you think that
you're saving money by living in the
truck or do you think that you're like
going out to eat all the time because i
can imagine it'd probably be difficult
like making breakfast lunch and dinner
in a truck it depends because there's
times when i'm in the truck and i'm out
on government land and it's like you
know there's nothing around and i'll be
out there for a week or two at a time
and there's like absolutely nothing i
you couldn't possibly spend money so
those are the times when i save money
but then also of course yeah like if i'm
for example i'm in vegas right now and i
i got a hotel because i'm not gonna
sleep in it in vegas and i was coming
from l.a got a hotel there too so
overall i would say the lifestyle
probably is actually more expensive um
it guzzles gas gets like not good gas
mileage it's more expensive to live in a
car than it is in a in an apartment uh i
would actually say yes if if you're
moving around a lot yeah um i would
probably say it's pretty close i mean it
doesn't have to be but it usually ends
up being that if you're like oh i'm
going to go to colorado this week and
that's going to cost you 200 in gas or
something you're not necessarily living
in the truck to save money yeah you're
just doing exactly right if someone
could do that if they wanted to yeah
yeah i feel like the question we're all
you know dying to ask here you too
graham me is yeah yeah alex too
say you meet a girl you fancy okay
how what do you what do you do
you know because i i'm in a struggle
right now i can't really you know a girl
that i i may like i can't bring her here
because it's someone else's house you
know i well i told jack he can't bring
bring uh randoms home you know that
that's that's not even the type of guy i
am
you were saying
but i'm not saying even if you meet her
like on a first date come back to the
house like you don't know somebody
really until like a few dates and i told
you i just go on a few dates and then
after a few days to kind of feel the
situation out then you could bring her
back here you're bringing around the
first date
are you bringing her back on the first
date no i'm not he's just saying that i
would i'm not saying you would wait
that's the first thing you told me i
just said the condition was
you know they're going to date you feel
them out just don't meet someone that
bring them back man
but uh yeah so what do you do when you
you know um
i built the truck for one person not
gonna lie there's there's no room for
anybody else in the truck has there been
no
no it's cool man no no there's actually
i i really i really regret not bringing
it over because you guys would see like
yeah the bed is like this wide right and
there's there's there's no room for but
what if there's barely room for yeah but
what if you met the perfect person you
you guys hit it off
uh i don't know has it happened i would
i cross that bridge when i get to it so
um
yeah tell us about your first night
though your first night living in the in
the trailer yeah the first night where'd
you go uh i slept in a walmart parking
lot in tennessee so you got out of your
posh apartment
yeah i it was a walmart parking lot in
tennessee and i it was a probably a bad
spot to to sleep over because it was
like it was definitely sketchy and then
somebody who lived in tennessee who like
it was in the area dm me and they're
like oh like welcome to my town or
something because i posted something on
my instagram story and i said yeah i
slept at the walmart last night and
they're like oh my god like that's the
worst part of town like you don't want
to be it so yeah that was the first
night um
but you know usually it's
pretty safe
i guess i mean i'm still here so did you
ever re-evaluate what what am i doing
doing this this this maybe i got it over
my head
no no i i don't think so
first i want to thank our sponsor ladder
i want to talk for a minute about the
things that have fundamentally changed
the way that we live these are
disruptors these are things like
smartphones streaming services and wider
than white paint that actually cools
down buildings and even things like
commission free trading another one i
heard of recently is a company called
latter who basically took the life
insurance industry flipped it upside
down and shook out all of the
inefficiencies before ladder if you
wanted to get life insurance you had to
drive across town sit through a sales
pitch fill out a ton of paperwork and
then wait six to eight weeks to find out
if you're approved alex can you wait six
to eight weeks for that six eight weeks
no one has time for that oh man alex
your voice sounds great dude anyway
you'd also receive a zillion phone calls
from agents trying to bundle your life
insurance with things like car insurance
now with ladder you can get fast and
affordable term life insurance without
leaving home it is 100 digital when you
apply for 3 million or less in coverage
no doctors no needles no paperwork so if
you're between the ages of 20 and 60 you
need coverage and want to team up with a
company that's redeeming life insurance
choose ladder when i went to ladder to
get my quotes they were so easy i was
able to do it right from my phone in
just minutes quit wasting time and check
out ladders today to see if you're
instantly approved go to ladderlife.com
iced coffee that's ladder l-a-d-d-e-r
life.com iced coffee
iced coffee thank you so much ladder for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
show
so let's talk about your financials how
do you make money
during this entire process yeah so i
mean i still do have youtube videos i
mean i make maybe one a month now right
um but
the videos like i have videos from three
or four years ago that are still getting
views so it's kind of weird um i mean
that my personal brand youtube channel
still you know like covers all the bills
that i might need
what does it make in these days um the
ad revenue on it it definitely went down
a lot because i i don't post anymore um
so i think it's like 17 or 18 grand
that's i mean that's incredible really i
think you guys are really
that's a lot of money yeah i mean i can
show you
yes yeah yeah yeah it's um
i mean it's just like old videos that
that
last time i remember we had you on about
a year ago maybe
i think you were doing like 40 40 50 a
month on your channel back then yeah and
you're posting like every other week i
think or every like third week and
you're also making like totally
different content like not money content
yeah it doesn't it doesn't make as much
um because i just kind of wanted to go
for the lifestyle content that i wanted
to make and kind of just do the channel
for fun now yeah yeah i mean you're
making content like the top books that i
wanted yeah it's just what i want to do
like i live in my truck or whatever like
yeah
i feel like i would get bored with it if
i was making the same content that i was
making two or three years ago this is
awesome i mean you're you're living by
the saying like it's it's not a sprint
it's a marathon yeah yeah i mean hey the
way i look at it is like as long as i'm
in the green every month and as long as
revenue's growing every month then i'm
i'm cool is it still growing every month
uh not my personal brand necessarily but
um in total you know just from any other
stuff that's going on any other stuff
well yeah tell us about this stuff
that's going on um yeah there's just
always projects you know like um i have
some other channels i've been working on
really yeah outsourcing and uh
wait a second what other channels i
thought you only had one channel oh nato
bryant show right oh yeah or the the
other one i do have that one yeah yeah
yeah and then don't you have one with
your brother i do yeah i had that one
too yeah and then um
yeah
that's all of them no tell it tell us
about the other channel you're holding
something back no i'm not i'm not
holding anything back i'm just uh you
know there's there's definitely
like
i'm i'm always working on something
right so like i'm not gonna just sit
around and do nothing so there's always
like investments and things i've been
spending a lot more time doing like
active investments right just other ways
to make money you know yeah i know you
went in on the amc blackberry nokia
thing right are you comfortable talking
about that uh yeah i can i can talk
about that yeah yeah that was fun i
don't know about this yeah
and build-a-bear too
build-a-bear wait a second yeah
yeah that was probably one of my better
trains that i've made so tell us a
little bit about what happened there
yeah walk us through the very beginning
how you found it where you saw it let's
hear this so it started with brian jung
called me up one day it was january like
early january and he's like nate there's
something brewing look at gamestop it's
it's like going up you know 10 every day
um and he was like still i don't know
the price what game of game stop was at
the moment but it was just brewing on
wall street bets it was picking up steam
um and and then we started to look at it
and we realized
amc was next
why how do you realize amc was nice you
could just see it brewing like it's it's
so hard right okay first of all first of
all i'm not just a like a degenerate
gambler um i have two like portfolios i
have my real like investment portfolio
and then i have my sort of like swing
trade sort of you know uh
gambling portfolio i guess you could say
that's like a lot smaller speculative
yeah speculative that that's my risky
portfolio yeah um and and so
we saw it brewing with amc and it was
like three dollars a share this was like
so early on and we just were like i
can't believe you found this like it's
it's gonna pop um
so what happened is i then
put in like i was so confident on it i
put an order for 60 000 shares
so what 180 thousand dollars rounded up
to 200 grand yeah so i put in an order
for 60 000 shares of amc went to bed
um and i think it was a market order um
but then like i woke up in a panic at
like five in the morning and i was like
i cannot do this this is like too much
too much speculation here so um i i
cancelled the order change it to 6 000
shares um
yeah i know um and so i think if those
60 000 shares if i would have actually
bought those at three dollars that would
have been went from three to uh peaked
at like sixty dollars a year right so it
would have been like 20 x yeah it would
have been like yeah like a few million
yeah but you can never look at it like
that because you wouldn't have sold it
necessarily you're lucky you still got
in yeah i i got in i got in so early i
got lucky with that um yeah nokia um
and blackberry i think i think i post
those on like my close friend's story
sometimes i don't publicize it to like
my followers because um i don't want to
like influence people yeah i don't want
to influence people and it's because
it's my speculative portfolio it's
really like yeah i'm not going to
publicize that um i think also uh chris
camillo right he made like a million or
two off of that that trade as well like
he did the same thing he bought amc like
so early on and then it like so you can
just see that like you can see it coming
up you know so what what did you sell
the amc at i used to hold it uh this was
after the little uh you know fiasco with
the uh
brokerage companies you know saying oh
yeah like out outbound only we're only
you're only allowed to sell yeah um so i
kind of like got hurt by that but um
i i don't know exactly how much i made i
mean it was uh i probably
sold it for like 10
12 maybe a share um definitely profit
because just because i got in so early
right so many people lost so much money
um
and i think
just like as a side note if you guys
like as a good indicator too of when to
get out of any type of like swing trade
or meme trade just whenever dave
buys you're at the top like with safe
when you portnoy
moon remember he was like you're going
all in on safe food next day down like
you know what i think it is yeah that
that's a good indicator by the time it
ends up on cnbc it's too late yeah
yeah always cnbc cnbc was the the the
front page headline everywhere when
robin hood went up to like 70 a share
that was the peak of the market right
there yeah and it's like really tough um
that's why it's my speculative portfolio
because it's it there's definitely like
a certain amount of like you can have a
good hunch you can have a good
understanding of it you think but it's
still like you got to be on the right
side of the momentum
yeah what did that portfolio start at
like what was the amount that you put in
you're like this is how much i'm gonna
risk um it was probably like a couple
hundred thousand okay like it was both
yeah like most of that portfolio when i
started it was like i'm dedicating this
it was like that 180 that was gonna do
for amc yeah so it's like about what it
started with by 200. and then now what's
it worth um okay so interesting um so it
it it definitely it went up to like a
few hundred thousand after the whole
thing like still ended up in the green
not as much as i was at like peak i was
up what like um
i think i doubled my money on on nokia
in like five minutes it went from four
dollars to eight dollars a share and i
made like 136 grand on that and then it
came down but
what okay so then eventually i was up
maybe like a hundred thousand or so just
estimated uh and then the meme stuff
died down i sold before like you know
didn't get left holding the bag on that
um and then
you could see it brewing again in like
april and may i like i remember i was on
the subway in new york and i just
overheard these transit workers talking
about amc coming back um and so i then
went back and bought 12 000 shares of
amc at like nine dollars a share in may
after it came all the way back down yeah
um sold it at 11
and then i bought build-a-bear with the
money that i used for amc
wow so you're just browsing the wall
here but but this is all day yeah yeah
but like i said this is really just like
this is like
the fun portfolio that like be
reasonable everyone
yeah yeah but also like there are
certain times when you just like you
have such high conviction on something
um and i've really watched a lot of the
dumb money guys videos um i think it's
really great and chris has some great
points um and there's times when you
just have like such like strong
conviction on something like with
build-a-bear uh which sounded crazy at
the moment um before they released their
earnings um back in may but
i think it's good to go in
pretty heavy when you're when you have
like really strong confidence on
something do you think the whole
momentum thing is starting to like
fizzle down a little bit yeah right now
it seems like it is um i i see no reason
why i wouldn't be back
at some point in the future like there's
no catalyst to like stop it from being
back um i think they think that i'll
stop like the whole meme stuff where
just like some random stock goes up to
hundreds of dollars is some type of
regulation um and i know the sec was
talking about that i think was sec or
whoever's in charge of that was talking
about like potentially like how do we
prevent securities from getting totally
manipulated by just like people it's
like a collective like yeah people just
pumping something up um what are your
thoughts about that
because you do have these big people
with these huge platforms they're like
you know what i like this stock a lot
i'm all in on it and they they could
very easily manipulate the price without
actually manipulating the prices they're
sharing their opinion but at what point
does that become
price manipulation like when you have a
million followers 10 million 20 million
and that's why
because i don't have the answer to that
that's why i don't talk about my trades
ever um like publicly because i don't i
don't even want to have
like anything like any problem you know
i don't want to have even like the
slight doubt that like oh i moved to
stock right because i think i like not
bragging but like i'm pretty sure if i
start posting stuff about hey i'm buying
this small cap stock it's gonna it's
gonna move um especially if it's like a
200 million dollar company like it
doesn't take a lot if it's really low
volume usually um it doesn't take a lot
to move that stock it's going to be
interesting interesting to see how that
plays out eventually because uh if
you're if your uncle jimbo is on
facebook with like three followers is
like i'm going all in on uh i don't know
yeah it's definitely
the fisker hurts because it's going off
50x nobody cares you're like oh uncle
jimbo that's just fine but meanwhile uh
let's say logan paul says the same thing
and it's like wait a second yeah
and it's just the difference of how many
people are listening but who's to say
you don't say something and that goes
viral and then then are you on the hook
for that yeah and i i think it also
depends on on like if you actually
believe in the company and you're
actually holding long term or if you
strategically like are planning on like
people do this with crypto all the time
um it's really unfortunate you know i
see so many influencers just like
pumping something up they're like buy
this buy this buy this like um and it's
yeah i just wouldn't want to be in that
right but here's where it gets iffy tube
let's just say of a price target of like
twenty dollars and it's a five dollar
stock you say hey guys i love this five
dollar stock i'm going to hold it until
it hits like 20 down the line imagine if
it hits 20 the next day like wait a
second i already hit my price tag i'm
going to sell
yeah um
i mean yeah like i'm not a lawyer so i
don't really know uh
what the the laws are on that so i just
deployed
that's smart what's in your other
portfolio uh it's mostly just um
like index funds you know vu
the simple ones like that um i bought
jets index fund i probably should have
unloaded that like a couple months ago
um because that's actually down since i
went into it last year um you know it
was up quite a bit like it was just like
the airline etf um but they've been
having some trouble lately yeah it's a
lot of those companies you know walmart
uh penn national gaming
uh you know a couple of fangs but uh i
i'm trying to really like consolidate
things and so that i don't have to
actively you know listening on the
earnings call from like 20 different
companies because i just feel like i
don't have the time for that now um and
i think it'd be foolish to sort of
blindly invest in like random companies
like apple for example i'm probably not
gonna have like sit down and listen to
their earnings so i'm not gonna go buy
their their stock
are you not focusing so much anymore on
the financials of your life because i
remember last time we met you it was
interesting meeting a personal finance
youtuber that didn't care so much about
like
saving like a little bit of money here
or like spending money here or raising
your income so much and it was that was
fascinating for me to see because i'm
not used to it are you still kind of
similar to that and graham was baffled
at that because it's like the opposite
of graham you know yeah i mean i think
there's a saying it's like you never see
um like a u-haul being towed by a hearse
or something right like
like you can't really bring your stuff
with you and um like in terms of money
you know uh i feel like i'm at a good
spot i'm pretty content with it and as
long as i have more money next year than
i have this year then i'm happy you know
and it doesn't have to be you know 10x
growth every year for the next 20 years
like i don't need to be a billionaire um
pretty content with where i am do you
have any like money goal or anything
like a net worth goal or anything that
once you hit that you'll definitely like
chill out or um not not really i i did
set those goals like when i was when i
was younger when i was like 17
uh when i was in college just like all
right i need to make a million dollars
by the time i'm 21 um and then i think
once you get to a certain threshold
everybody has a different threshold um
for me i think you only really need i
shouldn't say only but like
that's that's the wrong way to steer it
let's see how long i'm gonna put but
like i think you really only need like
a million um
to be set for life depends on the area
yeah a million in california first of
all
they're gonna take like 30 in tax yeah
cost of living is atrocious gas now by
the way in california started reaching
six dollars a gallon i paid five i paid
five dollars and forty cents on my way
here i just drove in
yeah
was it in bishop it was on the border
between nevada and california and i was
i had like 10 like 10 miles left like i
was like i need to get guests
yeah yeah they get you yeah i saw a
picture i i think it was on cnn at the
beverly center in la it was like six
dollars and 19 cents for premium wow six
dollars for gas for gasoline
it's one
supply i don't know what but um yeah
definitely everything's going up yeah
but a million could take you pretty far
in a lot of states yeah it's just i
think if you're a coastal state new york
california maybe maybe some more
expensive cities it doesn't yeah
but i i guess like kind of just the way
i viewed it is like
um yeah like i if i had a million i
could just live um and i don't have to
do crazy things like i'm i don't need to
spend a lot of money and i'll still be
pretty content so
yeah
so what are you spending your time doing
these days
aside from traveling in the car like
there's got to be some uh yeah um
just a lot of thinking i guess uh
meditating
um
thinking more
what do you think and also just like uh
socializing too you know i like a lot of
networking actually um i feel like i go
out to dinners quite a bit with
youtubers because because i travel a lot
um there's always like other youtubers
or business people in any space like any
city that i go to um so it's always i
love meeting people making connections
with people um and just making more
friends
yeah what do you think about moment
mostly just just life uh sometimes i
sometimes i don't even think
i don't know if i should say that it
makes me sound stupid but like like just
like really clearing your mind and just
and just being able to like really relax
and just like
enjoy the world existing yeah just like
existing some people probably don't
understand what i'm saying there but
like yeah just existing just living life
what's what's the biggest thing you've
learned from that experience so far
um
probably that
i mean you can be content like anywhere
that you are like um when i'm in my
truck in the mountains somewhere um
i don't really need like items and stuff
um i don't really need a lot and just
like
just living life yeah
have you ever had any dangerous
situations or anything that kind of
freaked you out
uh there were times yeah where um
like you know like i can lock my truck
from the inside and everything but yeah
there's times where you don't have cell
service and you're in the middle of
nowhere and nobody can hear you scream
so um yeah but otherwise i mean i'm i'm
still here so i feel pretty
mostly saying yeah
yeah shouldn't there be something where
if you are in a position like that like
no cell service like
your car broke down or something like
that shouldn't there be something like
where you could press a button and like
it says a gps signal that's a good idea
yeah i should definitely get one of
those should get a few flares yeah some
flares yeah um couldn't light those in
this area wildfires
um
yeah i should probably get one of those
i mean i guess like i oh i don't even
have a spare tire i have to get one of
those because if i break that like if i
get a flash i'm i'm screwed i'd have to
hitchhike somewhere so
have you ever had a hitchhike uh only in
yosemite so and that's like a really
safe place to hitch like you know
i think
yeah like you're not gonna get killed in
yosemite so
hitchhiking can be a little bit weird
though i kind of want to do it but it's
i feel like you need to do it with
somebody else i feel like it used to be
safer yeah and now it's it's a little
dangerous and you also have to think
about the type of person that would pick
up a hitchhiker yeah you know
yeah i mean have you never picked up a
hitchhiker no i've wanted to but i i was
usually in the car with my parents and
you know you don't really want to bring
a random person into a close quarter
with your child you know yeah
i would i would pick up danny duncan
if you see him on the side he's yeah
yeah but i picked somebody up once uh
when i was in colorado like two months
ago i think it was two months it was in
may um it's like yeah you can hop in the
back of the truck so
you know not going to kill that's good
yeah you want to keep a separate
compartment there yeah yeah yeah but
they're just trying to get like 20 miles
down the road yeah
so what about loneliness if you're if
you're kind of in the middle of nowhere
no one's around for like a week on end
yeah i think a week is is like a good
time um over a week yeah i'm sure you
would you could get lonely but i feel
like i i just have friends
like in most places so i'm always
hanging out with people um in a lot of
cases too i'll like meet up with people
who are also doing van life and living
in their cars and stuff and camping so
um and also i'm pretty introverted so
i'm like i get a lot of energy by being
by myself so um i've never really had
any problems with that yeah
that's fascinating you think you could
do that graham
uh i think for a few days i could
definitely do a few days at a time i
don't think i could do a full week
so i could definitely do probably three
to four days yeah yeah i would actually
agree with that like yeah three to four
is a good number i mean i've done a week
or more um but that's like a good number
and then you go back into a city
somewhere socialize right you know uh
yeah so how do you know where to park
and sleep
um so you you kind of just get to know
places and like you find a good spot
like this is the spot that like you know
um but there's there's an app actually i
think it's called ioverlander uh that i
use and you can see it has like a map of
everything that you can use like places
to sleep like places to park places to
take showers do do laundry like all
kinds of stuff like that internet um so
it's really really nice like it's like a
communal everybody contributes to it and
like hey this is a good spot right here
um so i i look at that all the time
that's how i figure out where i'm going
yeah i was about to say how do you
figure out showers and stuff like that
that's also never really been a problem
um i mean so
i do like uh
i'll stay in like airbnb sometimes
hotels sometimes so like what i was
saying with like how it's not cheaper um
just to like you know clean up and
everything and also friends um and then
using that app like you can find places
to shower i think i need to get a gym
membership like planet fitness or or one
of those uh i think that would really
help like kind of give more options for
that
yeah
i remember we did something last time
you here where we talked about the cost
of your outfit
okay okay you wanna you wanna run us
through yeah i mean um let's see i
actually don't remember how much this
was i just bought this the other day i
like zara so it was like probably like
30 or 40 dollars yeah um just because
you know i gotta look a little fresher
on the uh you know coming out of the
woods or desert or whatever so i didn't
want to walk around like a
dirty t-shirt or something um you guys
should have seen me like last week um
and then these i'm just wearing black
pants probably also you know thirty
dollars maybe um and then some socks
that i borrowed from my friend
jack what about your outfit wait is this
that's not that's not the new shirt is
it is it uh
no this is a different shirt oh you know
what we did we did uh we gave dragon
makeover oh really 100 makeover 100
makeover h m yeah good stuff there yeah
i mean five outfits the problem with
html is the stuff falls apart pretty
quick um
i would disagree all of my clothes are h
m in almost everything i've had for
years i do like their t-shirts that's
where i get my t-shirts from yeah
yeah my whole outfit's like really cheap
i think this shirt was like ten dollars
and i think these shorts were 12. wow
yeah i've never really understood the
like designer
clothes um yeah but i would see massive
lines outside of them um like i'll go to
malls
a lot and i don't buy stuff like i hate
shopping it just like is annoying um but
i just like walk around and just like
observe like things like how many people
are going like i'm i'm not counting how
many people are walking into a store but
just like observe things yeah um it also
helps with investing too like you know
looking at build a bear and it's like
hey there's there's a decent amount of
people coming in and out of there um but
yeah there's always so many people
outside of the gucci store louis vuitton
always has a massive line for the past
really since
um the first stimulus check came out and
not to say there's a correlation there
but it was around that time like when
malls opened back up and like um yeah i
definitely noticed something there did
you watch meet kevin's ex uh explanation
on that yeah so a lot of people disagree
with it too right on
uh
what are you talking about here so what
kevin said was when he was in las vegas
he went into was it a gucci or a louis
vuitton or a dr it was one of those
designer stores he walked in and he was
talking to the people about how busy
they were
and he said the people who worked at the
store said that they would purposely
price their handbags or their items
around what the stimulus check is
and knowing that people would go into
the store and be like wow this is kind
of free because i got the stimulus check
and this bag is like exactly 1200
or they would just try to upsell them a
little bit so like this one is 13.50 so
technically it's only costing me an
extra 150. yeah i think walmart did that
as well um for the maybe the first one
was the first one six hundred dollars
i think it was 12. okay so whatever like
the first one was or there was a second
one that was 600 right yeah okay so that
one i remember seeing in the news like
are people posting is like like the
walmart aisles there's just like you'd
see like 600 tvs 600 like items um so
yeah probably i mean i guess that's just
smart business uh to to kind of you know
realize that
like i hope i don't know how many people
got a stimulus check but you know over
100 million probably um so yeah it's
smart business
what about minimalism because i remember
last time we spoke as well you were like
very very into minimalism and obviously
like living in a trumpet truck it's hard
to have like quite a few things yeah
yeah so have you gotten more minimalist
than the last time we spoke
uh i i guess so yeah and how would you
say like the whole minimalism thing
affects your lifestyle and your overall
happiness like i remember i heard this
one thing where i think it was like
steve jobs or bill gates only has black
shirts mm-hmm because like it's fewer
decisions to be made in zuckerberg too
was it zuckerberg yeah the same thing
exactly so you wear the same thing every
day you remove a decision from your day
so you can focus elsewhere which is kind
of smart like like how would you say
your minimalism affects your life and
would you say generally it makes you
happier it definitely makes things a lot
easier um
you know like there's so many benefits
to it like if you have an apartment or a
house and you're a minimalist uh instead
of decluttering every week and putting
stuff back into their cabinets back into
the closets you can just get rid of it
and you save so much time cleaning um
you know like even with my truck too by
like having not a lot in it i can have
more space less time cleaning um and you
also save money too i don't really do it
for the money side of it but that
definitely is a benefit for people like
if you find yourself living a paycheck
to paycheck especially and you want to
cut something just like start really
thinking about do i actually need this
because there's always like you know i
go to people's houses and they have like
three different types of blenders
i i i don't know i feel like you can get
away with just one so
yeah
wow all right yeah i'm not coming at
anybody at 50. i have three i don't know
i think we have two blenders do we
really we have two yeah we have a magic
bullet and we have uh something else
yeah but they have but they're each for
a different purpose
every blender is like you need a big
blender for stuff but the magic bullets
were like you know just on the go just
you know a few things yeah it's easy
uh how much do you spend in a week we
gotta bring that back to what i spend in
a week
it's it's so hard to gauge because
there's there's weeks where i will
literally spend zero dollars i mean you
know there's probably like subscriptions
or something that'll like kick in or
whatever but um when i'm off the grid
zero dollars and then there's other
times where i'm traveling a lot like in
the past week i definitely spent you
know a decent amount of money because i
went out to dinner last night and the
night before uh business meals um
and you know hotel tonight that was like
100 some dollars so
there could be weeks where you know i'll
spend like a thousand dollars in a week
um
when you add everything in like i was
just over in europe in airbnbs for like
a month um so that probably costs at
least a few thousand dollars yeah
what do you think the average week
they're like a thousand bucks a week a
1500 if if if you're including business
expenses yeah then probably about a
thousand dollars okay yeah yeah like
just like business dinners or like um
you know business golfing
business recreation
no i i'm really concerned business
chipotle yeah no no no i like
not not to get into taxes but i'm really
conservative with like what i you know
like i don't write off that much because
i'm just you know want to steer clear of
any problems with that yeah now for for
your taxes uh
do you have to worry about being in a
location for too long and like oh i i
technically i filmed a video in montana
so now i got to file a taxpayer to
montana uh yeah my i talked to my
accountant about that kind of stuff a
lot um it does definitely like if i am
in a place for a really long time then i
would start thinking about that um and i
think there's certain places too where
like you have to pay tax based off of
how many days you were there
which is crazy um but yeah i mean i'm a
pennsylvania resident for now so uh and
i think i would only worry about that if
i was spending like a lot of time
somewhere yeah what's the state tax in
pennsylvania uh it's 3.07 percent that's
the top tax rate uh yes for personal um
so it's it's not terrible really that's
that's why three percent that's what is
is that a lot or a little no a little
yeah so that's why i haven't changed my
residency yet because like you know if i
was paying 10 or 13.3 in the top bracket
in california
i i definitely would would move yeah um
especially because i move around so much
that it's like why not establish
residency somewhere else
um you know got it yeah let me ask you
this i'm just curious because i think
the last time we talked you were getting
close to a million in a year right
uh a million subscribers no no a million
dollars oh yeah yeah did you were you
able to cross that uh with like my it's
like just everything on youtube yeah no
no just just with everything everything
combined uh why did we do that
yeah maybe yeah you did yeah wow yeah
congratulations
right like that included was pretty
significant i could imagine yeah you
couldn't include that yeah
congratulations good job thank you i
appreciate it yeah i don't i don't
really call myself like a millionaire it
feels weird like saying that but i guess
yeah i guess you could say that it's
it's weird because you're the only
personal finance youtuber you ask a
question you're like that and you're a
little bit reserved about giving the
answer even though like you got started
in finance yeah i'm like i'm a pretty
private guy yeah like you know and
people are surprised by that because i'm
sitting here talking about my life but i
still there's a lot of things i like to
keep private you know sure like yeah do
you does it make you uncomfortable to
talk about money and stuff like that it
does feel weird um like growing up my
parents never talked about money like i
have no idea how much money they make um
and they never talked about it and
that's just kind of like the culture in
my family um and i think that's like how
it is in a lot of households uh but also
like i think you know it was fun to talk
about it and i would do like those
income updates back in 2018 2019 yeah
and then it just kind of got to a point
where it just felt weird yeah you know
because like it went from people
cheering you on i'm like this is so cool
you're making like six thousand dollars
a month in college this is amazing uh
and i just kind of felt like you know
like too much like bragging almost um
and so
yeah that's why the last one i made on
income updates was like january 2020.
yeah yeah i could see that the same
something similar happened to me i think
originally when everyone started doing
it it was new
and nobody had ever done that before and
it was like wow they're just like
revealing all this transparency and
especially for someone like you i think
people have followed you from the very
beginning and they really support like
everything that you're doing and they're
excited for you and just you sharing
that little victory is like wow if if
nate could do it and he came from there
and i watched his journey then i could
do something similar too and if i if i
follow along like this is what's
possible so that's that's that's how i
originally went into it but then it did
seem a while like i think the last
income update
i don't know six months ago and that was
a lot i told jack even that one i was
like didn't want to do it but
you know i carried this on every year
yeah i may as well do one last hurrah
video on that but then after that it's
like
you're right in the very beginning it's
it's fun it's soon excited but then
after a while it's like okay this is the
the 20th update
yeah and like those videos always do
well people are interested like they
want to know and i think it's great like
it is good to be transparent because
it's um like probably thousands of
people have watched your videos and then
been like i'm gonna be just like graham
and then they went out and they did it
and now they're probably almost full
time like making thousands of dollars a
month because they they saw you come up
like this um and it inspired them so
yeah that's great now you know it's fun
too
uh in our last podcast we were talking
about videos that end up doing really
well told me to make a video on side
hustles
and back then i told you i hated making
videos inside because i feel like side
hustles don't really change
the same thing
uh well i made a video about side
hustles
because uh you know what you recommended
it that video is almost at a million
views yeah yeah and that's what happens
too like i i made up um
like
you know top seven businesses to start
in 2021 and i i make those every year
and it's like okay like people aren't
gonna watch this now it's 20 21 like
i've been making these for years yeah
and yeah that video is doing like it
gets you know three or four thousand
views a day yeah for the past year you
know so
those videos always do well so what are
some of the top businesses to start in
2021 um right now yeah let's talk about
first side hustles okay okay maybe the
top side top five okay side hustles and
then we'll do the top five ways to make
a hundred dollars a day in passive
income oh boy
i hope i can bring back the oldies
because i haven't made a video like this
in a long time um usually i spend a lot
of time like if i'm gonna make a video
like that i'm gonna spend days like you
ask like what do i think about it's that
kind of stuff like i'll just like pace
around all day and be like mushroom farm
you know
yeah i remember that
muscles uh i don't i don't know who made
this table but looks a little pricey
make his table oh you know what i do
think we got to give a huge shout out to
black forest wood co for this table
believe it or not they made this
entirely from from scratch look at this
well you can't really see we'll throw
some b-roll on this they included
coffee
inside the table which is incredible and
then they put this cool like glaze
through it it almost looks like a river
of coffee so we're going to put their
information down below in the
description
you know what we'll put up like a little
thing right here but thank you so much
and for anyone else who's interested in
a table like this they have some
fantastic products
yeah so what are we talking about side
hustle side hustles yeah i mean how like
there's
anything like that money is everywhere
and you can make money in anything like
literally you guys just got these right
yes black walnut right yeah black walnut
that's worth a lot of money okay and so
you could you can make these right like
i i remember because when my brother and
i we had a firewood business and
sometimes we'd stumble upon like black
walnut trees and those are worth a lot
of money and we knew that we could sell
these if we cut them into really large
pieces really large chunks we could sell
them to somebody who made things just
like this or made furniture made tables
um and you can get a premium for that so
like there's
money everywhere i feel like if you look
at your hobbies and and you analyze like
what do you love doing and then also
have a lot of knowledge about and then
just find a way to monetize it like
there's always a way sometimes you have
to be really creative with it um but
yeah that's what i suggest just coming
up with anything every side hustle is
viable in your mind yeah like i mean i
used to sell mealworms right um
the mushroom farm didn't didn't work out
unfortunately portabella mushroom wine
right by the way of course why that fail
i mean i was like 13 and just i it was
hard to find customers
um you know like
who's going to buy bags of mushrooms is
it it was it sounded like a good thing
in theory because pennsylvania produces
a lot of mushrooms um but it just you
know it was also like the shiny object
syndrome thing going on when i was 13 it
was like i was trying to find a business
i was trying to find something i'd get
excited about something to do for two
months and then find the next thing that
looked like a better opportunity you
know what's gonna take off i guarantee
this is gonna blow up
you heard it here first
growing funguses oh yeah yeah it's going
to be a huge thing i went to the uh oh
gosh what was the farmer's market the
other week and there was a table there
that was selling these kits the grow
your own fungus kits
i gotta say it looks so cool and all it
takes is for like a few viral tick tocks
to be like look at this [ __ ] and they're
cool looking i mean it looks like a
piece of coral that you could grow in
like no light that's easy to take care
of that that you could kind of do on
your own it doesn't take a lot of work
but you could give it the time it needs
they're just neat it made me want to
grow fungus like that and and i think a
lot of these are edible like you could
you could either not like poisonous
right you're gonna like have some crazy
experience but
it's it's just cool stuff and they grow
in all sorts of shapes and sizes like um
gosh what is this the the putty stuff
blew up like there are people making
like a hundred thousand a month selling
slime slime yeah really yeah like the
slimes and it's just you see these
instagram things of them like needing
the slime and it's it's just it's cool
to watch
fungus yeah
i think fungus could be a big one yeah i
should talk to my sister she's uh she's
going for botany for college yeah she
loves fungus she's always like sending
me like things about mushrooms all the
time yeah listen yeah i think you make
you make a a fungus kit that sends you a
new type of is a new type of fungus
fungus subscription seriously no there's
so much money in fungus seriously
because like i've i i saw a new company
that uh instead of packing peanuts they
use some type of like fungus or like
cardboard like instead of cardboard
biodegradable yes yes totally
biodegradable i forget what it's called
but there's just so many new things
coming out with it that it's definitely
an industry that's gonna blow up in the
next five ten years i feel like the name
fungus though could work against it like
like you don't want to like be like yeah
come check out my fungus farm yeah i'm
like you know eating my fungus
that just doesn't sound very appealing
fancier words for mushrooms like what
ah wow i'm blanking um
like mycelium my my
what is it uh
what the hell plant what is it
alex speaking of the mic uh it's not
calgary oh okay yeah it's a mycelium
yeah something that does sound pretty
fast look at this yeah is that a fungus
yeah so this is uh
yeah so look at this it's called golden
oyster mushroom grow kits
28
but look how cool that looks yeah you
just throw some mushroom spores in there
and uh
gets the job done that's neat and
imaginative every month
on the table right here yeah we should
that's pretty cool that's called lion's
mane i want more side hustles one more
give us another side hustle um gee i
mean
18 no money what do i do okay um you got
to look at your skills obviously and
everybody's
some so many people say i have no skills
like i'm totally worthless or whatever
everybody has something that you're
slightly better than the average person
at and it could be something really
stupid or it could be something like
really cool like you could teach people
how to surf like there's like look at
all of your hobbies and you can teach
somebody how to do that right you go
with guitar teach somebody how to play
guitar um you you speak you know uh like
spanish and and you know people who want
to learn spanish you can teach them that
right so teaching people to do something
great side hustle
you definitely know something that that
somebody's willing to pay money for so
and and the great part about that is
that there's really no overhead for it
right so it's not going to cost you much
money to get started with that
that's great that's a great answer that
is a really good answer i'm a little
curious like like you're talking about
all your different businesses and stuff
and and you say that you spend a lot of
time just kind of pacing and thinking it
seems like like you have more time and
i'm trying to get like a feel for like
where does the time go how i mean you
drive around in your car you you sit
places i'm sure like admire views i
always see you like you're in mountain
ranges and stuff like that like
um yeah i mean there's i
don't really know uh to be honest with
you um i mean it's definitely like
there's meetings obviously um i'm on the
phone with my brother a lot because he
i kind of do a lot of thinking and then
he does a lot of work i guess you could
say um so we kind of work together with
some business stuff
what kind of business stuff are you
working with yeah you're holding
something you're holding something back
what is it no i'm trying to figure it
out so if you don't want to talk about
you don't have to talk about it i mean i
just like a little bit i mean i'll just
say like yeah we have some youtube
channels uh some blogs um and then also
yeah a lot of my time is spent like
finding places to put money i guess so
like i don't like pumping all of my
money into the s p 500 so i'm looking
for new investments sometimes you know
there's like angel investments that get
pitched to us um but you know more so
looking for cash businesses that i can
invest into so i'm probably investing
into another media company uh in the
next couple of weeks i'm excited about
that probably can't talk about it like
here right now um and yeah just like
putting money into different projects
and kind of like setting things up like
we'll have some random business idea and
be like all right we want to do this but
we don't have any more time to go and
like try to build this business so we'll
just set up like a project basically
like and say okay put 25 grand into this
over the next 12 months and kind of just
let it run and then it should be
profitable by that end of the 12 month
period
now you say media company
and you say youtube channels can you can
you tell us
the youtube channels are like i don't
know about the names
i don't think so so
okay so if you can't tell us that the
channel is it that you're you're running
another channel or you you have some
sort of input on another channel that
yeah so like we revenue i'm not on the
channels like right because i like being
behind the scenes so so we'll just hire
somebody to to make the content um you
know script writers editors and they'll
just do all of that and it's kind of
just like
we'll just say like all right here's
what we're gonna do next here's the next
20 videos and go ahead and go make those
wow yeah and we just let them marinate
for a while like you know half a year or
something how have any of them taken off
maybe
i am so cute
hey you don't have to say you don't have
to say that that's awesome i'll show you
guys a little bit after okay that's the
podcast that's that's awesome man
congratulations on thanks
that's something that i wanted to do
originally before i i even started
making youtube videos i wanted to do
exactly that i wanted to invest in a
youtube channel and have some just
oversight i i thought a lot of channels
back in like 2013 could have done so
well had they just had like a business
mindset yeah and these were a lot of
channels that just they had really good
content but they had no direction in
terms of like how to monetize it they
were really good at being in front of
the camera they just needed someone to
take control of me like this is how we
should structure it we're gonna we're
gonna do this and make a lot of money
but to split it and what was holding a
lot of people back was that they were
still working jobs like the channel was
not making any money so they couldn't
give it a hundred percent they were like
you know working a job half the day and
then like going and doing this and it
just didn't turn out the same i wanted
people to do it full time yeah and i
guess that's where it kicks in where
it's like if you're so confident in it
you just say all right i'll like i'll
pay you like i'll make sure that you can
quit your job and do this full time
that's a bigger gamble obviously right
um but yeah people do that sometimes wow
all right last question on this before
we move on would this have been a
channel that maybe i would have stumbled
across
like maybe i had seen a video or like
probably not no actually no definitely
not okay
that's awesome
congratulations thanks that's so cool
it's pretty passive i'm assuming uh yeah
i mean it's past it's passive for me not
really for my brother that much um
like we we we're we're really good
business partners and i'm really happy
that like we have such a good dynamic
where it's like um not i don't this is a
good analogy but like let's say if like
if a business is a car like i'm kind of
the one steering the wheel and then he's
the he's he's the engine like he's the
one doing day-to-day operations like
really like making it work so um i don't
know maybe i should pick up the slack a
little bit but
wow
would you say then that's like surpassed
your own channel in terms of like income
geez wow that is so cool i am i am
shocked that uh that you're not just
like dancing around about this and like
screaming at the top of the mountain
this is incredible i don't see why i
would though
because you're the first one that uh
that i've talked to in the entire
finance niche that has managed to build
a second channel outside of their own
and manage it behind the scenes the
first person i've seen to do that see
it's just impressive to me that like
that you were able to do it with
yourself right and then you go and you
apply all of the knowledge that you had
learned and you weren't a part of the
equation at all as far as like using
your current celebrity to grow you know
but i think the hardest part of being a
growing channel is like understanding
the algorithm so i kind of got that part
down by building my own channel and then
you know what works you know it doesn't
work um going forward so it's easier to
just kind of like you know i'm sure
finding the right personality to be in
front of the camera very important yeah
very difficult yeah if you guys notice
sometimes i'll post like things on my
story with like google forms of like hey
anybody looking for like freelance work
yeah yeah i've seen that yeah yeah so i
just built like a big bank of like
hundreds of people who can wow script
writers editors be like people on camera
um
yeah see i'm i'm interested in just like
the pros like extremely interesting the
process behind like
i don't know how much of this you want
to talk about like this to me is the
most exciting thing that that i think
i've i've talked about all day here but
like the process be like what gave you
the idea
uh
like and you don't have to reveal too
much but like also why you chose not to
promote it through yourself like why you
wanted to grow it organically and not
like jump start from the very beginning
how you found people how you knew that
someone was gonna be good in front of
the camera did you have to let people go
in the meantime like yeah so i mean um
i'll just bring people on as like
independent contractors try out a couple
people right and then and then see how
they do um but i mean
so i really don't like i don't mind
being on camera but i'm not naturally an
entertainer i'm not naturally a speaker
so i really do prefer to work on things
behind the scenes um and there's just so
much opportunity with with youtube like
if you
have the
so let's say you have 25 grand
and you want to put it somewhere you
want to invest it somewhere without
spending too much time on it uh you can
put it into the stock market right i
feel like i'm already way over exposed
to equities um and you can put into real
estate you can put in other things maybe
grow 10 per year or something but i just
feel like with our understanding and not
to say like i have a superior
understanding of youtube in the
algorithm
but um like i just realized that you
know i could take 25 grand and instead
put it in the stock market put it into a
new brand and if that can turn 25 into
say 250 like you know that's a better
return than 10 so
that was kind of why we started doing
that
you're also diversifying like a lot out
of the finance niche obviously still
people get canceled every day you know
you don't want to yeah no that was why
that's why we started these wait really
no no not like the primary reason but it
was definitely like i was like i don't
want to have all my eggs in one basket
that's true i think the worst i i feel
so bad for people when
like they're an influencer they're doing
well and either like you know something
happens whatever i mean usually it's
their fault anyway um but there's also
times where it's like they start to slip
like their their videos are not as good
people don't watch them anymore and you
can just see like they're still trying
to make it like because they quit their
job they're doing youtube full-time two
or three years later they're not as
popular so now they're barely making
enough money to make ends meet and like
they have to do it because they don't
know what else to do um
i feel like a lot of youtubers get boxed
in and influencers in general and
they're like i have to keep doing this
to keep my money going so i can pay my
bills um and i didn't want to be in that
position
wow how do you know someone's going to
be good in front of the camera do you
just test things out until eventually
like you're like that's that's our
favorite yeah you just got to test out
are you afraid here's a weird question
are you afraid that um the person you
have in front of the camera is going to
feel like they're irreplaceable after a
certain amount of time and then they're
going to demand an amount that uh
really eats into the the bottom line um
that's why you put different people on
the channels
are we talking multiple so multiple
channels or one person per channel no
like multiple people per channel wow
okay yeah and and that way it's not like
it's yeah because i can see how that'd
be a problem if it was like one person
and they're making all the videos then
it's like people just associate that
person with the with the brand yeah so
that could be problematic that's really
smart you know what it reminds me of and
i'm not i'm not saying react no i'm not
saying this is what you're doing uh but
right now the dharman style video what's
that
really star man
i can't tell you maybe you're playing
this no no he doesn't know i genuinely
don't know what this is i use he makes
skits basically like really high
production quality skits that are
supposed to teach you some sort of
lesson lesson and they're super cliche
super just like typical and uh yeah but
oh my gosh so darman on facebook was
getting like over i think it was like a
billion views a month
a billion a month on facebook and you
know on facebook the monetization is
like through the roof yeah darman's
probably making like 50 million dollars
a year i'm guessing just from like
facebook his youtube channel blew up
when his youtube channel blew up and all
of his videos by the way are getting
like mr beast style views and he's
posting like multiple times a week
and uh that inspired a whole bunch of
copycats
who realized that format's working and
then the copycats go in and then their
videos just blow up because it's just
like these short little quick skits that
are easily shareable and the audience is
like you know your parents your
grandparents your uncle or whatever
they'll send you those videos what
boomers it is but you know but you know
what they're you know what the boomers
are doing that uh millennials are not
sharing
millennials rarely will send a video to
one another but meanwhile it's like
right what why millennials don't share
videos dude i get inundated with tick
tocks from people yeah yeah i guess
talks 100 tick tocks not youtube videos
though but on facebook it's so easy to
be like you know jerry come check this
out and
that's a dark jerry
i don't know young people now have the
name jerry i do a lot of cherries i
don't know
i'm just saying it's it seems like that
content is is more easily shareable yeah
they would take tick tocks you know no i
do agree like my mom out of everyone
does send me the most videos like out of
everyone my parents yeah and speaking of
tick tocks uh macy i checked my phone
she just sent me a tick tock oh yeah
yeah multiple he was like at least four
days that is like here's a funny tick
tock but it's easy because it's like 30
seconds it's so addicting yeah like like
that's why i i think that's why youtube
and snapchat and instagram like they're
all pushing me so much you know reels
and youtube shorts because they look at
how much time is being spent on tiktok
and they're like wow like we really are
dropping the ball here we we need to at
least keep up with tick tock because
that's the way content's going it's it's
it's scary because youtube is
slowly getting there
they're they're
i think uh youtube is trying to i don't
wanna say they're trying to copy the
algorithm but they're trying to create
their own algorithm to compete
and they're working on it right now yeah
i gotta say when facebook first came out
oh sorry when youtube first came out
with it uh was not a fan i thought like
this these are like silly things and it
just everything had the tick tock
watermark on it
they're getting better because now i'm
scrolling my homepage and i see them
come up with like it's always you know
what it is the teeth
it's it's uh getting plaque off teeth
for some reason is always the first
thing and and i want to watch it because
it's so sad
that's so i click it and then it ends in
like 10 seconds but it automatically
before you have time to click off it's
like here's the next one it's like and
they need to hit you like warps yeah
i've i've downloaded tick tock in the
past um i think i made like one tech
talk one time i saw it yeah and and um
i've downloaded in the past and it's
just like so addicting that i had to get
rid of it because you like oh just you
know two minutes whatever like you lay
down and go to bed you scroll and the
next thing you know an hour and a half
goes by and you think it was 10 minutes
like it's just it's insane it's it's i
want to see more studies on the effects
of tick-tock but i can see no but i
could see at some point
that uh like 10-15 years from now we're
going to look back at the effects of
what that does to the brain it has to
because i know even for myself i'm not a
fan of tik tok
but i know if you go on there it's so
easy 20 minutes goes by and i don't even
like tik tok so if that's doing it for
me imagine what it's doing for people
who like always go on tick tock and it's
just like this dopamine hits a bam bam
bam every like 20 seconds you get
something new that is algorithm tested
and what effect does that have on the
rest of your life that it's like every
time your mind goes blank open up tick
tock it's almost like a jug yeah and
that's something actually that i've
really been focusing on the past couple
of years that i've noticed my attention
span is so it used to be so bad um and i
think
and i've explained this my channel
before it's like if you look at movies
that were made in the 1970s like the
movie rocky versus a movie in 2021 like
in 2021 there's a yeah it has to be the
screen every three seconds is changing
but i remember watching rocky and it's
like there's like a five minute clip of
him just walking down the street like
nothing happening and i'm like come on
like something happened like i need
something action or something um and
it's just like it's getting faster and
faster like these dopamine hits are
getting like shorter and shorter and
shorter um so i don't know i feel like
something has to happen what do you
think that's what impact do you think
that's going to have the next uh
generation
uh i'm definitely worried um i mean
hopefully people can and you know this
is not like me saying that there's a
right and wrong answer if people want to
go watch tic toc for 10 hours a day they
can but i think just like realizing that
it can actually be almost like an
addiction it's like all right i need to
get rid of this and then really just
focus on
like
meditating actually is something that i
do because it really helps with that
with my attention span yeah and i think
having a good attention span it gives
you more patience it allows you to make
decisions better
some people say you lose your edge with
it a little bit but i think overall it
has great benefits reminds me a little
bit of the casino
like uh tic toc it's a weird comparison
but like when you walk into the casino
it's like they want to give you the
right conditions of like oh this this
machine is lighting up over here look at
all the numbers and just making i i
found it interesting i actually
i learned this from a tick tock believe
it or not
funny but uh i think it was was it
humphrey yang i think it was yeah he was
going through las vegas and he and he
pointed out why a lot of casinos don't
have hard turns you'll notice i saw that
one yeah there
there's not like a right and a left
there's always like you could go kind
and to the right kind of the left you
can go in a circle because they want to
limit the amount of decisions that you
have to make and the fewer decisions you
make the more likely you are to play
more yeah
they also get lost carpet the carpet is
always like a weird like psychedelic
design that just like it just calms you
down and makes you not think like the
carpets are always like that obviously
no natural light they don't want you to
see what time no
nothing and i'm i get so lost like i'm
like yeah i'm just gonna go outside and
like go get an uber or something i'll
spend 15 minutes trying like yeah
i'll walk a mile yeah to try to find it
um so that's also probably one of those
strategies as well just make it
confusing yeah but it reminds me of
tiktok if they they have this dialed in
to be like i'm going to show you this
video first and based on other users
like this if we show you this video a
second you're likely to watch that and
then they just keep testing this and
they test it millions of times for like
every video that you see to be like
perfectly tailored to you in just the
right amount of time and i bet they know
too like if a video is too long or it's
boring and people click out they're not
going to show that video again they're
going to show you something else that's
better everything you see is tailored
it's like per it's it's accumulation of
how many millions of hours of testing
that go into just the first few videos
that you see on tick tock this is bad
macy sent me a tick tock of uh people
trying
this is it uh clips exclusive guys so
you you have to go and subscribe to the
clips channel to go and see this if
you're game on this you don't have to do
it yeah well let's do it okay oh i know
what it is
i know what it is we're all gonna do it
together okay so don't think that like
we're going to subject just you to this
it is the world's most
sour candy
i'm taking this if we all want to yeah
if you want to
okay yeah yeah so uh i'm trying to buy a
house somewhere uh and i'm looking at
the different states that don't have
income tax right um just because it
makes sense like i don't have anything
holding me down so
might as well just go live somewhere um
that also i end up saving money and the
money i save in income tax will
basically pay for the house in a weird
way um so yeah i'm trying to figure out
that and i know you just moved to nevada
yeah um what are your thoughts on that i
love it it seems like so many people
have moved here now
okay yeah
yeah there's definitely people moving
here from california i see that like
yeah lots of my friends are just all
right but what about the property here
like i feel like it's
bubbly
no i i think
it is
okay so first of all everywhere is
bubbling there's not one place you could
go if you go like in the most rural
parts that's bubbly because everyone
wants to get out of the city every city
now is bubbly because people moved out
and people are like oh this is a good
opportunity i could get it
it's going to be the same no matter
where you go i think the benefit that
you have in las vegas is that
there seems to be such a huge influx of
people coming from california and i
gotta say they're the people who are who
are bidding up prices i bet if you go
and jack you would know this but i bet
if you talk to most realtors out there
in like the 500 to 1.3 million price
point and you ask them how many people
are coming from california how many
offers do you have from californians
they would say
at least 30 percent maybe half
and
what was it when i was looking even and
this was like a year ago over one and a
half million dollars they said the
majority of those buyers were from
california and new york wanting to move
here yeah that's the market so i would
say
in terms of property gosh las vegas
is fantastic you are competing with
california money coming in and
everything here is like relatively cheap
compared with air
but
they're they're doing so much
development right now that i just
i can't see how over 20 years like you
know
between now and like next year i have no
idea but i can't see how like 10 years
from now 15 years from now it wouldn't
be more expensive than it is today so i
think over 10 years i think it's a good
investment
yeah i'm definitely thinking about it um
i gotta check out vegas real estate i'm
probably gonna go down to houston
tomorrow uh look at some properties
you know not everybody loves houston
i've i've never been there but like i
know 10 people there and i always ask
them like how do you like houston
they're like it's all right yeah um
their their houses are
so cheap it's like you can buy a mansion
for a couple hundred thousand dollars um
so i want to check it out just like see
if i like the area because you wouldn't
want to live somewhere that you don't
like just for tax reasons i think that'd
be kind of like a waste like you know um
because that's where you're spending
your life right um there's some other
interesting options though like alaska a
little bit far removed all right uh
south dakota
wyoming not a whole lot of like
infrastructure there you know like if i
want to find like accountants and stuff
and like you know banks it's a little
bit more spread out um florida
obviously texas new hampshire i think
tennessee doesn't really have much of an
income tax now
uh in washington state so yeah
definitely some options says that's what
i've been doing exploring around with
like my truck i've been stopping through
the states looking at towns i think
there's just gonna be a time where it's
like it's just right like i stopped in a
city i stopped in a town like this is
the place
what's your favorite so far that you've
seen
um of of those states yeah um i would
probably have to say
uh obviously i i really liked austin i
mean i just liked how young everybody
was seemed like it was really up and
coming um you know doing well as a city
um property taxes were really expensive
but definitely like austin and you know
i like florida because it's so close to
everything else on the east coast i love
being east coast time like new york time
um so
yeah that's something i didn't consider
is this the time zone of it oh i can't
stand like being in pacific time it
kills me because i if i wake up here at
seven o'clock in the morning it's
already 10 o'clock like the market's
already opened and it you know it's
three hours earlier in new york um so i
love being on the east coast i actually
love being on europe time even better
like if you're in london um because then
you can you know wake up at you know 8
a.m and it's 3 a.m back in new york and
you're ahead of everybody you know so
you can really get the day started there
that's interesting yeah i think the
benefit of las vegas is that you're so
close to the to the west side and like
southern california so if you want to go
to the mountains you want to do all that
sort of stuff go to the future it's
really close yeah that's the benefit a
lot of people are also here they're
really business friendly no state income
tax um
but florida would be very tempting too i
think yeah a lot of people um miami's a
lot going on there so probably be a
little bit outside of of miami um up
closer to like you know boca or
something yeah yeah you mentioned that
you wanted to like maybe buy a mansion i
figured that that sounds kind of
atypical for that
well you said you can buy a mansion for
like a few hundred thousand dollars oh
yeah you could yeah um i mean i don't
want a huge house i'm thinking like 2
000 square feet maybe um that's not is
that average i'm not sure what the
average size is probably 1500 square
feet okay yeah so somewhere around that
is what i would go for so if i buy
something in in certain areas in texas
yeah it would be like you know probably
two hundred thousand dollars and at that
point i'm even wondering if i should
just buy it in cash and i know you're
gonna disagree with that probably right
uh
how much would you be looking for say if
it was like 200 000 or 250 000
cash yeah you think it's better i do i
do i'm happy that you say that because
yeah i'm leaning towards it yeah i just
think for your income and like your
position is it worth it to get a loan
yeah
financially it probably is because
you're going to be able to use that as a
good write-off but i also think that um
you know
is it worth it then to save like an
extra
that we'll call it like two grand a year
maybe it's how much you're gonna say by
having a by having a mortgage you're
gonna pay off um
maybe
you know two grand a year is that is
that worth it i don't know and this time
there's time involved with that too
because anytime you're self-employed i
feel like you know it's just
more problematic with home loans and
everything and i feel like i might just
be better off just doing cash and i kind
of view it uh in a way of like uh if if
you look at income if it's almost uh if
somebody was making 50 000 a year buying
a car in cash like it's not a huge
thing yeah i would say for you and
knowing your lifestyle and not having
like a lot of overhead i just think
having a mortgage for you i think would
be like another little
checklist in your mind on a mortgage get
paid this month uh uh and the one thing
i don't like with the the mortgage is so
silly but um they require that property
insurance is sent in every year and i
had one
that uh
it's not that it lapsed but there was
like a day or two where i forgot to pay
the insurance and they canceled the
policy but they have to send a notice to
the mortgage company and then they
issued me like a 35
like fee or something like that per day
that i didn't have insurance by mistake
um it's just like stuff like that is
just kind of silly i don't like that and
also
i mean you're not going to have this
issue but when you when you're getting
other loans
they want uh proof of your mortgage
payments on everything else with
property it's just like yeah
i don't know
beyond a certain point this is not
really worth it uh to save a small
amount yeah so i'm really happy you're
saying that because yeah i've been on
the fence because like most people say
you know why would you buy cash it
sounds stupid but uh yeah yeah but
financially it's probably a little bit
better but i think for you mentally
it'll be easier just pay cash be done
with it don't have any
lenders to talk to nothing like that if
you honestly if you put out one more
video
and the time it takes you to speak with
lenders shop around the rate send them
all of your information and closing the
house uh that one video would pay
probably double what you would save by
having a mortgage that year that was
that was my line of thinking as well
yeah yeah yeah it's not worth it yeah
so that's my response to you but uh i
think you would be happy in florida i
think you'd be happy and
a florida guy like florida man you could
the board is cool yeah oh yeah it's a
button yeah yeah you're perfect for
miami oh great yeah
but i could also see texas because if
you're looking to travel i mean that's
like right in the middle of the country
you could you could pretty much go
anywhere and be equal distance from like
the east coast as you could from the
west coast yeah and that's why i need a
big airport nearby so that's why i was
thinking houston maybe dallas yeah um
being within an hour of a major airport
because i just travel so much it's like
i couldn't be in wyoming that's why you
know right it's just too far off the
grid but why would you why would you buy
a house if you're planning on traveling
and doing all that stuff um i i want
because i want a place that i can like
have a home base at if i want to come
back and work for two months straight
like because there are times where i'll
just go and like a grind and i'll just
work work work work work right and i
want the ability to do that because
right now like you know i have my
apartment sometimes i'll go back to my
brother's house and just like his bunch
of rooms so i'll just like stay there
for a week and just crank work but i
want a place to do that um and also like
keeping the same address and everything
it would just be nice as well instead of
like imagining apartments and you're
moving around and you're like change all
your addresses like every year it just
seems like a big pain with like bills
and taxes and everything yeah so i want
a home base that makes sense yeah you
know what for something like that i i
just buy a place like 200 grand so the
you know we got one question it was from
a woman called sass and she just said
when will you get a haircut and i said
me or nate and she said both when are
you gonna get a haircut um you know i
actually
gave myself haircuts like most probably
more often than i don't
well wait i wear that wrong but you know
what i mean like i like i i give most of
my own haircuts um but probably i'll get
a haircut whenever i go back to
pennsylvania like back to my my when i
go visit my parents there's a barber i
like there and i only go to that barber
and i'm either going to the barber
cutting it or i'm cutting it myself
because i don't trust anybody else
wow jack
who cut your hair this last time i cut
my hair yeah actually for the first time
ever myself it's it's honestly better
like it might not look as fresh and
clean
but
it's quick it saves time saves money
yeah and you get better doing it like in
the mirror it's all like
reversed and stuff but like over time
you just get better with it why don't
you just do a buzz cut i feel like for
you
just yeah
you would look like tough really really
good
i'm gonna save the buzz cut for for when
i go bald you know like
oh just to clear it all up i might as
well just have the hair now like yeah
that's right everybody in my lineage
just goes bald so i was like all right
what age uh pretty early like 20s
so i really i mean your hairline is
airline perfect i hope i'm good i mean i
was actually analyzing that earlier
today is it's incredible all right yeah
well it's holding strong for now so
we'll see but um
yeah the buzz kind of feel like i'll
have plenty of time in my life where
i'll end up with buzz cut okay yeah
yeah i feel like you would you would
look good though with the buzz cut and
growth the beard a little bit oh yeah
should i grow out the beard because if
people are 50 50 on it and like i hate
shaving it's just such a pain yeah
when's the last time you've done that
what shaved yeah no grown it out i've
never
do it 100 do it grow it out just to see
what it looks like why would you not
yeah i guess so
i agree with that it's like 50 50 though
like it's the only negative comments
i've ever gotten like one time i didn't
say for like two weeks and people like
dude you need a razor man like
because you have a very youthful look
that when you're clean-shaven
it just it takes like 10 years off
yeah
that's what i think it is i think i'm
going to go beard because the fall is
coming up it's like going into winter
yeah right the warmth yeah yeah
you look pretty cool like with what you
got right right oh okay thanks i i think
i'm done shaving so i won't shave until
i come back on the podcast
wow yeah there we go five years old now
yeah
yeah cool awesome i think we're good hey
nate thank you so much for coming it's
been a blast thanks for having me guys
it's always great meeting up and uh i
love this new studio you have here this
is the first episode so congratulations
no we're honored
uh but one big question have you got
your free stock yet from public down
below in the description because they
raised it it's all the way up to a
thousand dollars now really really wow i
did get my free stock i used your link
yes
i also have a link but
use use the link in the description
below to get your free stock that's a
that's a good endorsement and and make
sure you you've finished you know
creating your account like don't don't
half-ass it finish your account connect
your bank account yes link it yeah link
your bank account and add the eclipse
channel down below in the description
yeah cool so with that said you guys
thank you so much for watching really
appreciate it nate thank you so much for
coming out here i will link to your
information down below in the
description feel free to add us on
instagram we post uh jack you gotta post
it more often on instagram yeah yeah now
that uh jack in the box is following you
jack in the box followed me on instagram
is that cool huge that's big yeah you
better get that sponsor yeah giant box
if you're watching right now feel free
i'll take anything okay i'll take
anything so you wanna give me a jumbo
jack to eat it on the podcast i'll do it
that would be incredible for them to
sponsor the podcast like just an episode
where we just have jack in the box jack
in the box it's so good i love it i'd be
fine with that so jack in the box we
gotta make that happen uh also black
forest wood company
thank you so much for this table i will
link to their information down below in
the description i can't speak of this
table highly enough it's incredible you
have to like truly see it in person to
appreciate it but if you want any work
done similar to this
10 out of 10. you're absolutely
incredible so thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
this one
okay yeah call should i go